welcome to this video playing
Grandmaster reckless reckless reckless
I don't know from Israel D 496 yeah this
is one of the guys with the most games
on Isis see I'm pretty sure let's have a
look for funny statistics 229,000
one-minute games that's quite a lot 229
Wow okay so we have a sort of chigorin
defense to the Queen's Gambit now I
played c4 late but I went for it just
delaying it for a moment
to get the bishop out of the pawn chain
yeah I'm not sure about them precise
move on us here I think there is
something like e 5 here u 5 actually not
that one
okay okay vy castle castling coolness 92
maybe taking and queen g3 playing on the
dark squares yeah that should be okay
for wide I mean it's not like I'm having
a big edge or anything but it should be
an okay position it's a very good Bishop
on their phone yeah this is this is
strange move why would you go to a five
here Wow yeah it does not it does not
make much sense to me but that's seen
just taking a c7 year what what is he
doing to pro protected Wow 97 and then
what exactly it's going to give up the
exchange of there's a six hanging and
they say eight hanging and 96 was also
quite strong but
hmm they're very weird this is looks
like it costs heavy material ok 96 just
taking the pawn and don't forget that
he's got the knight on a five which does
not have any square so with this III and
III and the B form also possible okay um
here
yeah even d5 is a good move contending
Bishop to e5 on ninety five minutes both
good night g5 rook somewhere a3 and
before mouth okay I need to I need to be
a at least bit quicker here the only
real way to lose this game is on time or
blundering the Queen or something but
other than that white is overwhelmingly
for preference iam okay Bishop to e5
Knight is six night XE for a second pawn
and not sure why the Queen should go if
not to g6 we're working go to e7 or
something I go just not h3
this wins the second pawn you didn't
have any good square anyway I know you
need to trade even I mean Queen Queen
somewhere that's not f6 picking up the
rook okay okay
does this you can do yeah just trading
Oris them is it better to move the
knight some we're not sure Jack I'm keep
let's try to keep it simple this is this
should be a good enough really age five
chat page five and then 92 I don't think
he can go to g5 this looks like looking
for a self-made
yeah it still does look like looking for
a self-made mm yeah well I can't go F
wines and put it push the King to G for
King King F to ends yeah he's playing
without a five and I cannot believe it
at all so let's go here yeah you can of
course he can he can after that you can
take on e3 and on g3 but check before
traps tonight I mean what doesn't it
yeah knowing the king is also and quite
a bad spot probably black resigned well
yeah just a very weird way to play here
this this is I think even a theoretical
position and there are ideas I think
maybe here with with E 5 quickly like
that and E 5 trying to use the fact that
I'm a bit slow with my king out of the
center something like that I believe is
right but not I'm not 100% sure yeah now
if I cancel it's got an ID to so I need
to address that so I took and put the
Queen here which seemed okay to me but
it's not like fatal of course like black
can play something like yeah of course
oopsie aid or something but also there
should be six is a good move this okay
castles a 95 is just sorry it's just
crazy this move I mean I don't
understand it at all you you won't ever
get C form and you just after that what
is winning really c7s is impossible to
protect anymore and what he played it
seems is technically speaking at least
from the computers point of view the
best line and then this means if that's
the best that black can get get it just
terrible yeah here there also was defy I
saw this idea intending Bishop e5 but I
wanted to play it like keep it simple
just attack the rook and this looked
like keeping everything under control
yeah okay we can go to e7 to not get
into 94 but I'm going here and he's
playing without this piece on a5
and you put it just there voluntarily
okay yeah she takes this is winning
young Czech wouldn't be surprised as if
that's some kind of medium c5 is also a
strong trapping both pieces they are
both both trapped on the side of the
body check okay but this is also also by
far enough to win the game
there are various mating ideas the
easiest being rook h1 h2 h1 rogue edge
for checkmate and very tough to defend
guy to be played that check he have just
before to pick up this yeah this is
really unlucky knight on e5 alright
thanks for watching